From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。
This is going to take a while because there's so many pictures.
这可能要花点时间，因为照片实在太多了。
Yeah, he definitely defeated the system a little bit here.
是啊，他绝对是在这儿耍了一点小聪明，钻了系统的空子。
Laura Mayer's the editor in chief of her high school yearbook, and she's noticed that last year's book had a problem. In a lot of the club pictures, there's one kid who appears over and over and over, too many times to actually be in all the clubs.
劳拉·迈耶是她高中毕业纪念册的主编，她注意到去年的册子有个问题。在很多社团合影里，有一个孩子频繁出现，次数多到根本不可能参加了所有的社团。
I think he probably did this all in one day. Let me take a look. I know he's in In the Mood for Food Club, which their slogan is we love to cook and eat. He's in Military History Club. He's in Lawn Sports Club. He's in Out of the Box Club, which is-- do you need to know what that club is?
我觉得他可能一天之内就把这些都搞定了。让我看看。我知道他在“美食心情社”，他们的口号是“我们爱烹饪和吃”。他还参加了“军事历史社”、“草坪运动社”和“跳出框框社”，就是——你需要知道那个社团是干什么的吗？
I don't need to know, but now I'm sort of wondering what that is.
我倒不需要知道，但现在我有点好奇那是什么了。
Sort of wondering. Well, they go on these excursions that are not inside the box, but out of the box.
有点好奇吗？嗯，他们会去参加一些“不在框内”的郊游，也就是“跳出框框”的活动。
And the box, in this case, is the school building?
而在这种情况下，“框框”指的就是教学楼？
Yeah, I guess. It was sort of like thinking, you know?
对，我想是吧。大概就是一种思维方式，你知道吗？
They're thinking outside the box.
他们是在“跳出思维定势”。
Yeah, thinking outside of the box.
对，跳出思维定势。
I wonder what one of those excursions would be?
真想知道其中一次郊游会是什么样的？
Well, I know that they went to see a Led Zeppelin laser show, Turkish belly dancing, and they visited a corn maze. So it's actually a really popular club. He's in that picture.
我知道他们去看过齐柏林飞艇的激光秀、土耳其肚皮舞，还参观过玉米迷宫。所以这其实是个很受欢迎的社团。那张照片里也有他。
I would think the laser show would actually still be in the box.
我觉得激光秀其实应该还算在“框内”吧。
Yeah, I know. I'm pretty sure belly dancing and corn maze, I think nobody would dispute those are outside the box.
是啊，我知道。但我敢肯定肚皮舞和玉米迷宫，没人会反驳说那是在框外。
Yeah. I guess that is sort of leaning towards being inside the box. He's in Photo Club.
嗯。我想那确实有点偏向于“在框内”了。他还参加了摄影社。
Now is he doing anything in these pictures? Does he look like he's somebody pulling a prank?
那他在这些照片里有做什么动作吗？他看起来像是搞恶作剧的人吗？
In some of them, he does. In the two-- the ones I just looked at, the Lawn Sports and Military History Club, he looks like he's pulling a prank. A interesting grin on his face. But in the In the Mood for Food, it seems like he's being a little bit more smooth about being in the picture.
有些是。在我刚看的两张，草坪运动社和军事历史社的照片里，他看起来确实像在搞恶作剧。脸上带着一种有趣的坏笑。但在“美食心情”社的照片里，他似乎表现得更自然，没那么刻意。
What's he look like?
他长什么样？
He's got very curly hair. I actually know his name.
他头发很卷。我其实知道他的名字。
What's his name?
他叫什么？
Sam Melnic.
山姆·梅尔尼克。
Sam Melnic?
山姆·梅尔尼克？
Yeah. I know of him, but I don't know him. I think my brother might know him actually.
对。我听说过他，但不认识。其实我弟弟可能认识他。
In the back of the yearbook is an index listing all of the students and then sending you to the pages with their pictures. And at Laura's school, if you have so many photos that your listing in the index takes three lines, people notice.
毕业纪念册后面有一个索引，列出了所有学生并标明了他们照片所在的页码。在劳拉的学校，如果你照片多到索引要占三行，大家都会注意到。
You know you've made it when you've got three lines, I'd say.
当你名字占到三行的时候，你就知道你“火”了。
That's just like a known thing?
这是大家公认的吗？
Well, definitely. Because your name sticks out and it's like you've accomplished something, I think. I mean, it's a joke, but I think a lot of people take it a little more seriously than-- yeah, someone like Sam Melnic, he may--
当然。因为你的名字很显眼，我觉得这就像你完成了什么了不起的事。我是说，这只是个玩笑，但我认为很多人比我想象中要认真得多——就像山姆·梅尔尼克，他可能——
You're flipping to the back now?
你现在翻到后面了吗？
Yeah, I'm flipping through the back. Melnic. Oh, he has three lines. Wow, he has a lot. He has 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14 entries, and that's huge. I mean, I have like nine, and I'm one of the editors. So I can respect that him getting 14 by like bucking the system. That might be the most, one of the most out of anyone in the book. It's got to be.
嗯，我正在翻后面。梅尔尼克。噢，他占了三行。哇，他真的好多。他有14个条目，这太夸张了。我是说，我才9个，而且我还是编辑之一。所以我很佩服他能通过这种钻空子的方式拿到14个条目。这肯定是全书里最多或者数一数二的了。一定是这样。
I don't know, it just seemed funny at the time. You know, me and my friend decided to get in as many pictures as possible.
我不知道，当时就觉得很好玩。你知道，我和我朋友决定尽可能多地出现在照片里。
America, meet Sam Melnic. He says it wasn't just the talking his way into all those photos that was satisfying.
美国，认识一下山姆·梅尔尼克。他说不仅是靠嘴皮子混进那些照片让他感到满足。
I felt more of a sense of accomplishment when I opened the yearbook and I saw the numbers.
当我翻开纪念册看到那些数字时，我感到更有成就感。
Did you actually go to your friends and say, check this out?
你真的去跟朋友说，“看这个”了吗？
Yeah. And I said, hey, look, I have-- like you have like a 10 number, or something, and I like the most in the yearbook.
嗯。我说，嘿，看，我有十几个条目，或者类似的话，而且我觉得我是册子里最多的。
Did you actually have the most photos in the yearbook?
你真的是纪念册里照片最多的人吗？
Actually, I think there's actually two people with the same name who had more than me. But I think I had the most.
其实我觉得有两个人跟我同名，他们比我多。但我应该是最多的。
Wow, that's a huge achievement.
哇，那真是巨大的成就。
I mean, you just walk into photos. Anyone can do it if you put your mind to it.
我是说，你只要走进镜头就行了。只要你有心，谁都能做到。
You guys have to meet.
你们俩得见一面。
Yes.
没错。
If this were a romantic comedy, if this were a movie right now, you guys would end up in love.
如果这是一部浪漫喜剧，如果现在是电影情节，你们俩最后会相爱。
I know. There'd be lots of music and--
我知道。会有很多音乐，然后——
But also, you'd be arch rivals for a while because you'd be trying to keep him out of the yearbook.
但也可能会先成为死对头，因为你会试图把他从纪念册里踢出去。
Exactly. He'd be like the yearbook nemesis, but then something would happen. There'd be an epiphany or something, like over a template, and that's how it would work. Yeah, and then that would be the turning point in the story. I can see that.
没错。他会成为我的纪念册克星，但后来会发生点什么。可能会有某种顿悟，比如通过一个排版模板，事情就是这么发展的。是啊，那将是故事的转折点。我能想象到。
Now, of course, Sam Melnic doesn't give a damn if the yearbook is accurate. If it's actually a history of their senior class for decades to come. But what's interesting is that Laura isn't too bothered about his prank, either. Is this kind of thing got out of hand, she says, sure, that would be bad. But one or two kids jumping into some pictures and doing it so effectively?
当然，山姆·梅尔尼克根本不在乎纪念册准不准确，也不在乎它是否能作为未来几十年的高年级历史记录。但有趣的是，劳拉对他的恶作剧也不是特别反感。她说，如果这种事失控了，那肯定不好。但有一两个孩子高效地跳进几张照片里？
Yeah, I respect that. I think that type of thing adds to the charm of the yearbook.
是的，我尊重这一点。我觉得这种事反而增加了纪念册的魅力。
It tells a little story.
它讲了一个小故事。
Yeah, it has a story. It adds character to the book, I think. I think it was funny, personally. I don't know how the other editors would feel, but I appreciate it.
对，它有故事。我觉得它给册子增添了性格。个人而言，我觉得这很有趣。我不知道其他编辑怎么看，但我很欣赏。
Now I bring all this up because I have a thing or two that I need to say to you about Benjamin Franklin. One of our contributing editors, Jack Hitt, has a little obsession with Franklin. He reads all those Franklin biographies that keep coming out. And he's interested in how Franklin has this kind of cheerful disregard for the truth in certain situations. There are certain situations where Franklin-- one of the people who through his writing and his action defined what it is to be an American, after all-- where Franklin happily jumped into club photos where he didn't belong in the high school yearbook. If you know what I mean. Here's jack.
我提起这些是因为关于本杰明·富兰克林，我有几句话要说。我们的特约编辑杰克·希特对富兰克林有些痴迷。他读遍了所有出版的富兰克林传记。他很感兴趣富兰克林在某些情况下对真相那种轻描淡写的无视。在某些时刻，富兰克林——毕竟他是通过文字和行动定义了何为美国的人之一——他曾快乐地把自己“跳”进了他不该出现的社团合影里。如果你们懂我的意思。下面是杰克。
Probably the most famous image we have of Franklin is him standing out in an oncoming thunderstorm flying a kite with a key on a string and I don't think it's true.
关于富兰克林我们最有名的图像可能就是他站在暴风雨中，放着一只系着钥匙的风筝，但我认为那不是真的。
In fact, a lot of people don't think it's true. A biographer named Tom Tucker tried to replicate the experiment for a book called Bolt of Fate , and he failed. A bolt of lightning hitting the kite could have actually killed Franklin. And most telling of all, in the 1750s, when all this was supposed to have happened, this experiment was supposed to have taken place, Franklin wrote that a kind of experiment sort of like this might be possible, but he never wrote anything saying that he'd actually done it.
事实上，很多人都觉得这不是真的。一位名叫汤姆·塔克的传记作者曾试图在一本名为《命运之雷》的书中复制这个实验，但他失败了。一道闪电击中风筝实际上可能会杀死富兰克林。最能说明问题的是，在18世纪50年代，也就是这一切本该发生的时候，富兰克林写道，这类实验也许是可能的，但他从未写过任何内容声称自己真的做过。
If you had actually proved your own theory, don't you think you might have run around and said, hey, it's true. I'm right.
如果你真的证明了自己的理论，难道你不觉得你会到处去说：“嘿，这是真的，我是对的”吗？
But in fact, he didn't do that at all?
但事实上，他根本没那么做？
No, he didn't tell anybody. We only know about the kite story decades later. He didn't write about it at the time. And when he did write about it, it's really vague. He doesn't tell us where he was or who was there except that his son was there.
没有，他没告诉任何人。我们几十年后才知道风筝的故事。他当时并没有写出来。而当他后来写到时，措辞非常含糊。他没告诉我们他在哪，也没说有谁在场，除了他的儿子。
So I think what happened was, many years later, when Franklin's looking back over his life, he's got your bifocals and the Franklin stove, and he's got the insurance company thing. But then his real great sort of scientific contribution to the world is electricity.
所以我认为发生的事情是，许多年后，当富兰克林回顾一生时，他有了双光眼镜、富兰克林炉和保险公司这些成就。但他对世界真正伟大的科学贡献是电力。
But the problem with electricity is that it didn't make a great story. Franklin had had a theory that lightning was a kind of electricity, and he encouraged experimenters to stick metal rods in the air to get hit by lightning, which guys in various countries did and actually proved him right. Which, like I say, kind of prosaic. Not sexy.
但电力的问题在于它没法成为一个好故事。富兰克林曾有一个理论，认为闪电是一种电力，他鼓励实验者在空中竖起金属杆去捕捉闪电，不同国家的科学家确实这么做了并证明他是对的。就像我说的，这太枯燥了，不够吸引人。
But he knew that creating an image like him flying a kite was going to last a lot longer in people's minds than guys standing next to steel rods sticking up in the air.
但他知道，创造一个像他那样放风筝的形象，会比一群站在钢杆旁的人更容易留在人们心中。
Yeah.
没错。
And it did. If you ask any child who Ben Franklin was, they will tell you the kite story.
确实如此。如果你问任何孩子本·富兰克林是谁，他们都会告诉你风筝的故事。
One thing that's so crazy that the idea that he made all of this up is that this was not somebody who needed to pad his resume for history. He was Benjamin Franklin. He edited Thomas Jefferson. He wrote the line, "We hold these truths to be self-evident." He created the postal system. He invented stuff. He created an American style of writing. He convinced France to fund the Revolutionary War, without which we would not be a country. If Benjamin Franklin felt the need to pretty things up a little bit for his legacy, why wouldn't Sam Melnic?
有一点极其疯狂，他编造这一切的想法，他根本不是那种需要为了历史给简历贴金的人。他是本杰明·富兰克林。他编辑过托马斯·杰斐逊的文章。他写下了“我们认为这些真理是不言而喻的”那句话。他创建了邮政系统。他发明了各种东西。他创造了一种美式写作风格。他说服法国资助了独立战争，如果没有他，我们可能就不会是一个国家。如果本杰明·富兰克林都觉得有必要为自己的遗产进行点修饰，那山姆·梅尔尼克为什么不能呢？
Which brings us to the subject of today's program. Today on our radio show, we bring you stories of people trying to control how they're going to be remembered. People who invent their own kite and key stories. People who run into the club pictures for clubs that they're not part of. And in most of our stories, I have to say, it turns out it's not so easy to control how people are going to see you years from now. It doesn't go too well.
这引出了今天节目的主题。今天在我们的电台节目中，我们将讲述人们试图掌控自己被后人铭记方式的故事。那些发明属于自己的“风筝与钥匙”故事的人。那些跳进不属于自己的社团合影的人。我不得不说，在我们的大多数故事中，最终你会发现，想要掌控人们在多年后如何看待你，并不容易。结果往往不尽如人意。
Act one of our show, "Thinking Inside the Box," in which someone has a message for an audience of exactly one and plots carefully how to get her to receive that message. Act two, "Where's Walter?" Starlee Kine has the story of a haunted Ramada in Fond du Lac, Wisconsin, and the man who haunts it and how he's remembered. Act three, "Giving Up the Ghosts." Shalom Auslander explains why he decided to stop remembering the dead, even though his job actually required him to remember. Stay with us.
第一幕，《跳出框框》，其中有人给唯一的目标受众传达了一条信息，并精心策划了如何让她接收到这条信息。第二幕，《沃尔特在哪？》，斯塔莉·基恩讲述了威斯康星州丰迪拉克一家闹鬼的拉玛达酒店，以及纠缠在那里的幽灵和人们铭记他的方式。第三幕，《放弃幽灵》，沙洛姆·奥斯兰德解释了他为什么决定停止纪念死者，尽管他的工作其实要求他去纪念。请继续收听。
Act one, "Thinking Inside the Box." David Wilcox has this story about what it is that people remember.
第一幕，《跳出框框》。大卫·威尔科克斯讲述了这个关于人们记忆的故事。
My sister Jenny's five favorite songs are all looped, back to back to back, on a 90-minute cassette that has been dubbed so many times now most of the singing sounds like a chipmunk buried beneath a mud slide. It starts off with Jenny's favorites song, "The Greatest Love of All" by Whitney Houston. Jenny fell in love with it at the height of its popularity 20 years ago. And in the years since then, not a day has gone by when she hasn't listened to it.
我妹妹珍妮最喜欢的五首歌被做成循环，在一段90分钟的磁带里反复播放，因为翻录次数太多，大部分歌声听起来就像埋在泥石流下的花栗鼠。磁带以珍妮最喜欢的歌，惠特尼·休斯顿的《至高无上的爱》开始。珍妮在20年前这首歌最火的时候爱上了它。从那以后的岁月里，没有一天她不听这首歌。
Billy Joel's, "The Longest Time" follows, along with two songs from the movie The Jungle Book recorded directly off the TV. It is, unequivocally, the worst mix tape of all time. And lest you think I'm exaggerating, please consider the most recent addition to the tape recorded by Carly Simon in 1986. I defy you to make it through this song in its entirety even once, let alone the thousands of times the members of my family have.
紧接着是比利·乔尔的《最长久的时间》，还有两首直接从电视上录下来的《森林王子》里的歌。这绝对是有史以来最糟糕的混音带。为了让你们相信我没有夸张，请考虑一下1986年卡莉·西蒙录制的最新的那首。我敢打赌，你们连一遍都听不下去，更别提我家人们听过几千遍了。
[MUSIC- "ITSY BITSY SPIDER" BY CARLY SIMON]
[音乐——卡莉·西蒙演唱的《小蜘蛛》]
This is the sort of music SWAT teams bring out as a last resort during a hostage standoff. And, strangely enough, it's also how my sister makes it from one day to the next.
这是SWAT特警队在人质对峙时作为最后手段才会播放的音乐。但奇怪的是，这也是我妹妹度过每一天的方式。
How could somebody listen to this every single day? You would have to be mentally retarded. Which, it turns out, my sister is. I know how that sounds. I know it's bad to use the R word. But in 1970 when Jenny was born, she was simply, as my parents were informed shortly after her birth, retarded.
怎么会有人每天都听这个？你得是精神残疾才行。而事实证明，我妹妹确实是。我知道这听起来怎么样。我知道用“那个R开头的词”是不对的。但在1970年珍妮出生时，医生告知父母她就是有智力障碍。
The official diagnosis was severe and profound, which meant she would never learn to walk, talk, feed, bathe, or dress herself. And the doctors recommended, as they often did back then, that she be sent to live in a state institution. But my parents kept her at home, and while my dad worked, my mom dedicated the rest of her life to teaching Jenny everything she'd never be able to do.
官方诊断是严重和极重度，这意味着她永远无法学会走路、说话、自己吃饭、洗澡或穿衣。医生和当时常见的一样，建议把她送到国家机构寄养。但我父母把她留在了家里，虽然我爸爸要工作，我妈妈致力于用余生教珍妮所有她本该做不到的事情。
Today, Jenny's capable of far more than anyone could have predicted. By that, I mean she can walk, talk, swim, use a fork, recognize colors, and recite the alphabet, if you help her along. She went to the same high school I did and even has a job doing light assembly at an assisted living facility. But at the same time, she's little more than a four-year-old. Life for Jenny is exactly like life for a toddler, filled with simple pleasures, structured around a set routine in which any day, like the day before, is a good day. Which brings me back to the mix tape.
今天，珍妮的能力远超任何人的预期。我的意思是她能走、能说、能游泳、能用叉子、能认颜色，在帮助下还能背诵字母表。她和我上了同一所高中，甚至在一家养老院做些简单的装配工作。但同时，她也只相当于一个四岁小孩。珍妮的生活就像蹒跚学步的孩子，充满了简单的快乐，围绕着固定的日常习惯，每一天都像前一天一样美好。这就说回了那盘混音带。
When you meet Jenny, it's one of the first things you find out about. When she's not listening to it, she's talking about it. She carries it around for hours in anticipation and she's sure you want to listen to it with her. She even used to follow people around the house with it blaring from a Fisher-Price cassette recorder.
当你见到珍妮时，你会第一时间发现这件事。她不在听的时候，就会谈论它。她会带着它好几个小时，确信你也会想和她一起听。她甚至曾经带着费雪牌录音机到处播放，跟着人后面跑。
There have been other fixations throughout Jenny's life, though none as significant as the tape. There was the old Monkeys TV show, a British cartoon called Danger Mouse , videotapes of Cinderella, and, of course, The Jungle Book .
珍妮一生中还有过其他的执念，虽然都没有这盘磁带重要。曾有过老版的《猴子乐队》节目，一部叫《危险鼠》的英国动画片，还有《灰姑娘》的录像带，当然还有《森林王子》。
And you wouldn't believe how excited this stuff makes her. She literally squeals every time it comes on. It's so genuine and sweet that you can't help but be excited for her. It makes you want to give her the next thing she feels this way about.
你无法想象这些东西让她有多兴奋。每次播放时她都会尖叫。那非常真诚又可爱，让你不禁为她感到兴奋。这让你想把她同样感兴趣的下一件东西也送给她。
At one time a few years ago, my mom actually made Jenny a video. My parents didn't have a camcorder, so she asked a neighbor to come over to the house and shoot it. And on the video, my mom gives a tour of Jenny's favorite things.
几年前，我妈甚至给珍妮拍了一段视频。我父母没有摄像机，所以她请邻居过来拍。视频里，我妈带大家参观了珍妮最喜欢的东西。
This is the best thing we ever did. Because she can put the video in by herself. And it will start and play through and rewind and eject and turn off and she doesn't have to do anything. I haven't had to watch Jungle Book in a year and a half. Which, you have no idea.
这是我们做过的最棒的事。因为她自己就能把视频放进去。它会启动、播放、倒带、弹出并自动关机，她什么都不用做。我已经一年半没看过《森林王子》了。你根本无法想象这意味着什么。
Two years before my mom made this, she was diagnosed with lung cancer. By the time they discovered it, it had spread to her lymph nodes, which meant all she could do was start chemotherapy and hope for the best. Remission came and went. The cancer spread to her brain, then to her bones.
我妈拍这段视频的两年前，她被诊断出患有肺癌。等发现时，癌症已经扩散到淋巴结，意味着她只能开始化疗并祈祷。缓解期来了又去。癌症扩散到大脑，然后是骨头。
By the time this was recorded, she had begun hospice care and was coming to terms with the inevitable.
这段视频录制时，她已经开始接受临终关怀，并开始接受不可避免的结局。
I'll show you her costumes. I think I'm going to take a marker and mark stuff as to whether it's work, play, dress-up.
我给你看看她的戏服。我想我会拿记号笔把它们标出来，分清哪些是工作穿的，哪些是玩的，哪些是打扮用的。
Death isn't something you can explain to Jenny. All she knows is that you're gone, and once you're no longer a part of her day to day, her memory fades.
死亡不是你能向珍妮解释的事情。她所知道的只是你离开了，一旦你不再参与她的日常生活，她的记忆就会消退。
My mom used to have this running joke that when she was finally gone, Jenny wouldn't even notice. But at the same time, it wasn't a joke. So she made this tape hoping it would be the sort of thing Jenny would watch every evening after dinner on the TV in her bedroom. The one that starts, plays through, rewinds, and ejects without her having to do anything.
我妈过去常开玩笑说，当她终于离开时，珍妮甚至都不会注意到。但同时，这也不是个玩笑。所以她拍了这个磁带，希望这是珍妮每天晚饭后在卧室电视上观看的东西。那个无需她动手就能启动、播放、倒带和弹出的设备。
My mom spent a lot of time planning this tape, but you wouldn't know that from watching it. She seems nervous and unsure of what to say, like someone had just pulled a camera out on the spot and told her to start talking. Parts of it are completely inaudible. There are these choppy cuts where the tape starts and stops.
我妈花了很多时间策划这段录像，但从视频里看不出来。她看起来很紧张，不知道该说什么，就像有人突然拿出摄像机叫她开始说一样。有些部分完全听不清。视频中有一些突兀的剪辑，磁带时断时续。
And because of the chemo, she barely even looks like herself. She's wearing a wig, her body doesn't look healthy, her voice doesn't even sound that much like her. If you listen closely, you can hear her try to catch her breath, winded from just walking around the house.
而且因为化疗，她看起来几乎不像她自己了。她戴着假发，身体看起来很不健康，声音也不像她了。如果你仔细听，能听到她试图呼吸，仅仅是在屋里走动就让她气喘吁吁。
Her dress up stuff's in here. She's got a flapper. How about this for hotsy-totsy? She looks so cute in it. And her cheerleader stuff. She's all fixed up. Billy will have to figure out what to do with it. But he will.
她的打扮用的东西都在这。她有一套舞女装。这件可爱吗？她穿上肯定很可爱。还有她的啦啦队装。她都整理好了。比利得想办法处理这些。但他会做好的。
Most of it's just like this, shots of closets and bedrooms, a tape of my mom not saying what she's really feeling to someone who can't understand it anyway. Instead, she explains Jenny's daily routine to the neighbor who's behind the camera. Then at the end there's an edit and suddenly, she's sitting on my sister's bed, finally talking directly into the camera, directly to Jenny. It's one of those moments people go over in their heads a million times, the last thing you might ever say to someone you love. Where every word is supposed to be eloquent and moving and memorable. But, with someone like Jenny, you do exactly what my mom did. You keep it simple and you tell her what she can understand.
大部分内容就像这样，拍摄着壁橱和卧室，一段我妈对着一个即便看了也听不懂的人说着心里话的视频。相反，她向镜头后的邻居解释珍妮的日常作息。然后在最后有一个剪辑，突然间，她坐在我妹妹床上，终于直接对着镜头，直接对珍妮说话。这是人们在脑海中演练过无数次的时刻，你对挚爱之人说的最后一句话。每一个字本该是优雅、动人且令人难忘的。但是，对于像珍妮这样的人，你做了我妈所做的事情。你保持简单，告诉她她能理解的事情。
This is your room. You know you're supposed to make your bed up here every morning. And that's not going to change. You can come up here and watch a video as long as you don't do it 24 hours a day. Maybe Daddy will get you a boombox all your very own if you'll be good and not want to listen to it all the time. But you have to do other things. You have to help Daddy around the house and that kind of thing.
这是你的房间。你知道每天早上都要在这整理床铺。这一点不会改变。你可以上来看看录像，但前提是不能24小时一直看。如果你表现好，不总想听它，也许爸爸会给你买一个属于你自己的录音机。但你得做其他事情。你得帮爸爸做家务之类的。
And that's the moment, the one moment where she says what she's feeling. "You have to help Daddy around the house." She's going to be gone and it's just going to be my sister and my dad, and she doesn't know what they're going to do without her. This was my mom's way of telling Jenny that she wasn't abandoning her. A way to be there on demand, whenever she was needed.
那一刻，是她唯一表达感受的瞬间。“你得帮爸爸做家务。”她即将离去，只剩下我妹妹和我爸爸，她不知道他们没有她该怎么办。这是我妈告诉珍妮她没有抛弃她的方式。一种在她需要时随时出现的方式。
A few weeks after the funeral, my dad put this video on. Jenny didn't even watch it through to the end. Soon, it wound up at the bottom of a drawer, sandwiched between The Muppets and Barney the dinosaur, who my sister also once loved, and now has forgotten.
葬礼几周后，我爸爸放了这段录像。珍妮甚至没看完就关了。不久，它就在抽屉底部躺着了，夹在《布偶》和她曾经也爱过现在却忘了的《恐龙巴尼》之间。
And while it's sad to think that she doesn't want to see it, it's a comfort to know she doesn't need to. She doesn't need to hear her voice or remember her face. She doesn't wonder where our mom is or when she's coming back. It's as though Mom never existed. And while I'm sure that would break my mom's heart, I'm also sure she would want, as she always did, whatever was best for Jenny. Even if that means she's forgotten.
虽然想到她不想看这很让人难过，但知道她不需要看是一种安慰。她不需要听到她的声音或记住她的脸。她不奇怪妈妈去哪了，也不奇怪她什么时候回来。就像我妈从未存在过一样。虽然我肯定这会让我妈心碎，但我同样肯定，像她一直做的那样，她会希望这对珍妮来说是最好的。即使这意味着被遗忘。
That's the weird advantage to being Jenny. The bigger the change, the less she understands it, and the more she concentrates on what stays the same. While the rest of us struggle with memories, she simply forgets. If only we were all so lucky.
这就是身为珍妮的奇怪优势。变化越大，她理解得就越少，她就越专注于保持不变的事物。当其余人还在记忆中挣扎时，她只是选择了遗忘。要是我们都能这么幸运就好了。
David Wilcox is a Texan living in Chicago.
大卫·威尔科克斯是一位住在芝加哥的德克萨斯人。
There's an organization that's recording people to preserve their voices and stories for their children and generations to come. It's called StoryCorps. They have an audio booth in Grand Central Station in New York City. They're building others around the country.
有一个组织正在记录人们的声音和故事，以便为他们的孩子和子孙后代保存。它叫StoryCorps。他们在纽约中央车站有一个录音棚。他们正在全国各地建设更多的录音棚。
From time to time, you can hear some of the stories and voices they've gathered on public radio. Here are two stories that they recorded in New York.
偶尔，你可以在公共广播中听到他们收集的一些故事和声音。这里有两个他们在纽约记录下的故事。
The first one is this guy who has thought quite a bit about what he's going to be remembered for. The second is a bus driver who has never forgotten one of his customers.
第一个是一个对“自己会被铭记为什么”思考了很多的家伙。第二个是一个从未忘记过他的一位乘客的公交车司机。
Everybody got something in their life that they're good at. This is what I do good, I eat. I was always a bigger eater than most people in my family. And about five years ago, there was an ad in the paper for a matzoh ball contest.
每个人生活中都有擅长的事情。这是我擅长的，我能吃。我一直比家人更能吃。大约五年前，报纸上有一个关于吃“马佐球”比赛的广告。
I went down to the contest, I broke a record. I ate 10 matzoh balls, half-pounders the size of baseballs, in 2 minutes, 50 seconds. No one ever ate more than 10. And I went on to the finals and I won. And Mayor Giuliani gave me the trophy. And the announcer said, let's hear it for Don Lerman and Rudy Giuliani. And we're both shaking hands like the president and the vice president-elect. That was the first trophy, the matzoh ball trophy, ever in my life.
我参加了比赛，打破了纪录。我在2分50秒内吃了10个半磅重的、像棒球那么大的马佐球。没人吃过超过10个的。我进入了决赛并赢了。朱利安尼市长给了我奖杯。主持人说，为唐·勒曼和鲁迪·朱利安尼喝彩吧。我们像总统和副总统当选人一样握手。那是我一生中第一个奖杯，马佐球奖杯。
I always wanted to be famous. I always wanted to be president, or a big lawyer, or a doctor or something, and it just never happened. I had a couple of day-old bread stores. That was my business. I worked 80 hours a week, 7 days a week. I just thought the parade would pass me by until eating.
我一直想出名。我一直想当总统，或者大律师，医生什么的，但这从未发生。我开了几家卖隔夜面包的店。那是我的生意。我每周工作80小时，一周7天。我以为游行队伍会绕过我，直到我开始吃东西。
My father never lived to see me famous and he always thought I was a loser. I wish he was alive to see that I'm a somebody.
我父亲没能活到看到我成名，他一直认为我是个失败者。我希望他能活着看到我成了一个人物。
I remember one woman, in particular, a senior, who had gotten on my bus and she seemed completely lost. I could see she was confused. I don't know whether it was an illness, but she looked so beautiful for a hot summer day to have her fur on. So I said, are you OK? She said, oh, I'm fine. I'm fine, but I don't know a restaurant. I'm meeting my friends. I said, you sit on the bus. I'll run in and I'll check each restaurant. The very, very last one on the left, I said, it's got to be this one. So I said stay here, sweetie, it's nice and cool in here.
我记得一位老太太，她上了我的车，看起来完全迷路了。我看出她很困惑。不知道是生病了还是什么，但在炎热的夏日里，她穿着皮草看起来很美。所以我说，您还好吗？她说，噢，我很好。我很好，但我不知道餐馆在哪。我要去见朋友。我说，您坐在车上吧。我跑进去查看每一家餐馆。左手边最后一家，我说，一定是这家。所以我说，待在这里，亲爱的，这里凉快。
I went in and I said, there's a lady in the bus and she's not sure the restaurant. And I saw a whole bunch of other seniors there and they said, oh, it's probably her. So I ran back to the bus. I said, oh, sweetie, your restaurant is right here. And I said, no, no, don't move. And I grabbed her hand. I remember my right hand grabbed her right hand. I wanted to make her feel special, like it was a limousine. It's a bus. She said she felt like Cinderella.
我进去说，车上有位女士，她不确定是哪家餐馆。我看到其他一群老年人，他们说，噢，可能是她。所以我跑回车上。我说，噢，亲爱的，您的餐馆就在这。我说，不，不，别动。我抓住了她的手。我记得我的右手抓住了她的右手。我想让她感觉很特别，就像在豪华轿车里一样。这只是一辆公车。她说她感觉像灰姑娘。
And she said, I've been diagnosed with cancer. And today is the best day of my life. Just because I helped her off the bus. And I never forgot that woman.
她说，我被诊断出患有癌症。而今天是我生命中最美好的一天。就因为我扶她下了车。我永远不会忘记那位女士。
Ronald Ruiz, a New York City bus driver on the City Island Line in the Bronx. Before him was Don "Moses" Lerman, who's a competitive eater. He attends big events on the International Federation of Competitive Eating Circuit.
罗纳德·鲁伊兹，纽约布朗克斯区城市岛线的一名公交车司机。在他之前是唐·“摩西”·勒曼，一名竞吃选手。他参加国际竞吃联合会巡回赛的大型活动。
Act two, "Where's Walter?"
第二幕，《沃尔特在哪？》
Our next story is a story of a man trying to control his legacy using all the normal means that a person can, and pretty much failing pretty completely. It's a story that Starlee Kine kind of stumbled into by accident.
我们的下一个故事是一个男人试图用一个人能用的所有正常手段来掌控自己的遗产，却几乎完全失败了。这是一个斯塔莉·基恩无意中闯入的故事。
Not long ago, I had to go to Fond du Lac, Wisconsin, for work. So I went online and found one of those sites that booked hotels. This was a typical review for the Fond du Lac Holiday Inn.
不久前，我去威斯康星州丰迪拉克工作。于是我在网上找了一家预订酒店的网站。这是丰迪拉克假日酒店的一条典型评价。
"If you want a nice vacation, but don't want to spend gobs of money, this is a place for you. Friendly staff, nice pool, great continental breakfast. The only problem was the elevator was a little slow. Oh well."
“如果你想要一个不错的假期，但不想花太多钱，这是个好地方。员工友好，游泳池不错，早餐丰富。唯一的问题是电梯有点慢。噢，算了。”
And this was the typical review for the Fond du Lac Ramada Hotel.
这是丰迪拉克拉玛达酒店的典型评价。
"Service was great. The good was good. They're redoing their bar and it looks awesome. Only problem was that something sat down on my bed while I was sleeping. And I was alone. I felt a hand resting on my chest. It felt like my mother used to do when she would try to calm me down at night. It brought back a pleasant memory, but if left me a bit on edge after that."
“服务很棒。食物也不错。他们正在翻修酒吧，看起来很棒。唯一的问题是当我睡觉时，有什么东西坐到了我的床上。而我是一个人。我感到有一只手放在我的胸口。感觉就像我妈妈过去在晚上试图让我平静下来时做的那样。这勾起了我一段美好的回忆，但之后让我有点不安。”
How could I pass up a recommendation like that?
我怎么能错过这样的推荐呢？
So tell me about the ghost.
跟我说说那个鬼吧。
He's Walter.
他是沃尔特。
He's Walter. He's the ghost that likes to haunt us.
他是沃尔特。他是那个喜欢缠着我们的鬼。
Have you seen Walter?
你见过沃尔特吗？
I haven't seen Walter, but I've felt him around here.
我没见过沃尔特，但我感觉他在我们这儿。
Yeah? What's that feel like?
是吗？那感觉是什么样的？
Scary. Yeah, it's like a tingle up your back.
很吓人。是的，就像背上起了一层鸡皮疙瘩。
The Ramada Hotel is in Fond du Lac, Wisconsin, right off of Highway 41. And Walter is the ghost of the hotel's original owner, Walter Schroeder. Almost all of the staff, most of them teenage girls, have had firsthand experiences with Walter. The staff keeps a log of every last door rattle or crashed drinking glass or glowing light attributed to him.
拉玛达酒店位于威斯康星州丰迪拉克，就在41号高速公路旁。而沃尔特是酒店原始业主沃尔特·施罗德的鬼魂。几乎所有的员工，大多是十几岁的女孩，都有过和沃尔特的亲身接触。员工们记录下了每一声门响、每一次玻璃杯碎裂或灯光闪烁，并将它们归咎于他。
The biggest entry by far is what happened in room 717. It's a classic. Here's Becky, the girl who works the weekend shift.
最轰动的条目是关于717号房的事。这是经典。这是周末上班的贝基。
What happened in room 717?
717号房发生了什么？
Oh, that one. OK. I guess there's a guest that called down about a complaint coming from one of the rooms that they could hear screaming for help. And at the time, Emily, who was the desk manager, was working. And she followed procedure, had maintenance go up there and check.
噢，那个啊。好吧。有个房客打电话投诉，说听到房间里传来呼救声。当时 desk manager 艾米丽在值班。她按程序办事，让维修工上去查看。
And maintenance went up there and they went to 717 and the door was shaking, like someone from the inside was kicking it and pounding it and screaming for help. And they keys would not work to get into the door. And then, all of a sudden, it stopped. And he went into the room and there was nothing there.
维修工上去到了717号房，门在晃动，就像里面有人在踢门、砸门并尖叫呼救。房门钥匙怎么也打不开。突然间，一切都停了。他进屋后发现里面什么也没有。
He told Emily that the room was empty. There was nobody in the closets. He said from the force of the kicking on the doors, there should have been marks on the doors. But there was nothing. I'm getting the goosebumps.
他告诉艾米丽房间是空的。壁橱里也没人。他说以踹门的力度，门上应该有痕迹才对。但什么也没有。我起鸡皮疙瘩了。
There are long lists on the internet of hotels that try to lure guests in with promises of paranormal activity. That talk more about their ghosts than they do their room rates. But the Ramada in Fond du Lac has a refreshingly non-exploitative relationship to its ghost. Its bar is not called the House of Spirits, its restaurant isn't called the Haunted Hamburger. They don't sell, "My grandmother went to Fond du Lac and lived to tell about it" t-shirts in the gift shop. In fact, it doesn't even have a gift shop.
网上有长长的酒店名单，试图用超自然活动的承诺来吸引客人。他们谈论鬼魂比谈论房费还多。但丰迪拉克的这家拉玛达酒店与它的幽灵之间有一种清新且不带剥削性的关系。酒吧不叫“灵魂之家”，餐厅也不叫“闹鬼汉堡”。他们不卖“我祖母去了丰迪拉克并活着回来讲这个故事”的T恤。事实上，他们甚至没有礼品店。
Nope. No, the only way you'll find out about Walter is if he chooses to make his presence known to you by say, pulling your hair, or switching the channels on your TV. The hotel says his favorite is C-SPAN.
不。唯一的发现沃尔特的方式就是如果他选择向你展示他的存在，比如拽你的头发，或者切换你的电视频道。酒店说他最喜欢的是C-SPAN。
And according to the staff, as far as types of ghosts go, Walter's more of the annoying variety than the scary. His lot in the afterlife is to get blamed whenever anything goes wrong. He's basically a scape ghost.
而且根据员工的说法，沃尔特的鬼魂类型更倾向于烦人而非吓人。他在来世的任务就是任何事情搞砸时被责怪。他基本上是个“替罪鬼”。
Well, one time me and a coworker were counting the money and all of a sudden it disappeared. And we counted it several times over and over repeatedly and it wasn't there anymore. And then all of a sudden it showed up.
有一次我和同事在数钱，突然间钱消失了。我们数了好几遍，反复数，钱就是没了。然后突然间它又出现了。
And that was Walter, you think?
你觉得那是沃尔特？
Yeah.
是的。
I came on my shift and I opened the till. I put my money in. I made one transaction all night. When I went to cash out, it was short-- do you remember what it was?
我来接班，打开收银柜。放进我的钱。整晚我只做了一笔交易。结算时，缺了——你记得缺了多少吗？
$5.
5美元。
Yeah, it was short like $5 and some odd change. And it was really strange because nobody else had gone in the till. And it was just simply gone.
对，少了5美元多一点的零钱。这很奇怪，因为没人碰过钱箱。它就这样凭空消失了。
The computer, it beeps. It just beeps all the time and then I just tell it to shut up because I think it's Walter. I think he took a picture of me one time, me and another girl I was working with. We saw just a flash from the balcony. We didn't know what happened.
电脑会报警。它一直响，我只好叫它闭嘴，因为我觉得那是沃尔特。我觉得他有一次拍了我和另一个女孩的照片。我们看到阳台上有闪光。不知道发生了什么。
What would Walter want to do with a picture of you?
沃尔特想要你们的照片干什么？
I don't know. I just tell him to go away because he bugs me.
我不知道。我只是叫他走开，因为他烦我。
I spent a total of five nights at the Ramada and didn't really feel a presence, as much as I tried. I wandered the halls whispering Walter's name. I took Polaroids in hopes of capturing a spirit waving from inside the vending machine. I found the spookiest, most clearly hauntable place in the hotel, the locked ball room, and pressed my nose against its glass doors trying to spot the ghost inside.
我在拉玛达一共住了五晚，尽管我很努力，但没感觉到什么存在感。我在走廊里徘徊，低声呼唤沃尔特的名字。我拍了宝丽来照片，希望能捕捉到一个在自动售货机里挥手的灵魂。我找到了酒店里最阴森、最容易闹鬼的地方——锁着的宴会厅，把鼻子贴在玻璃门上寻找里面的幽灵。
The closest I came was the night I fell asleep with the TV on. When I went to bed it was on one channel, and then when I awoke the next morning, it was on another. Not C-SPAN though, but the Bible channel.
我最接近的一次是那天晚上开着电视睡着了。我去睡时在一个频道，第二天早上醒来时它换成了另一个。不是C-SPAN，是圣经频道。
Other hotel ghosts usually stick around because they've been wronged in some way, or met an untimely death. At the Holiday Inn in Buffalo, a little girl ghost named Tonya burnt to death in a house that once stood there. Now she's always jumping on the hotel beds.
其他酒店的幽灵通常留在那里，是因为他们受了某种冤屈或意外死亡。在布法罗的假日酒店，一个叫托尼娅的小女孩鬼魂在曾经伫立在那里的房子里被烧死了。现在她总是跳到酒店床上。
In New Mexico, a beautiful young maid named Rebecca was killed by a jealous lumberjack. And now her ghost likes to talk on the telephone in the governor's suite.
在新墨西哥州，一个美丽的年轻女仆丽贝卡被一个嫉妒的伐木工杀了。现在她的鬼魂喜欢在州长套房里讲电话。
At the Golden North Hotel in Alabama, Mary lies waiting for eternity for a husband to return from his gold rushing expedition.
在阿拉巴马州的金北酒店，玛丽永远等待着丈夫从淘金探险中归来。
And all the ghosts who haunt the Queen Mary Hotel in California were victims of accidental drownings. Except for the cook, whose food was so bad, he was murdered.
加州玛丽女王酒店里缠绕的幽灵都是溺水事故的受害者。除了那个厨师，因为他做的饭太难吃被谋杀了。
But the odd thing about Walter is that he doesn't even have a motive. In fact, I was shocked that no one on staff was even the least bit curious about why Walter would have stuck around.
但奇怪的是，沃尔特甚至没有动机。事实上，我很震惊员工中竟然没有人好奇沃尔特为什么要留下来。
So why do you think Walter would choose this hotel?
那么你觉得沃尔特为什么会选择这家酒店？
I don't know.
不知道。
I have no idea.
我完全不知道。
我不知道。
I really don't know.
我真的不知道。
I don't know.
我不知道。
What could a man have done in his life that was so horrible, so wrong, so unbearably tragic that he'd be condemned to wander for eternity the halls of a Ramada hotel? I decided to try to find out on my own, which meant doing some research.
一个人在世时做了什么如此糟糕、如此错误、如此难以忍受的悲剧，以至于他被谴责要在拉玛达酒店的走廊里徘徊到永远？我决定自己找答案，这意味着要做些调查。
Before there was Walter the ghost, there was Walter the man. And before there was a Ramada, there was a Retlaw, which is what the hotel was called when Walter originally owned it. Retlaw is Walter backwards. Retlaw. It's just so ridiculously creepy, so redrum, that it's hard to not suspect that Walter had this whole ghost thing planned all along.
在沃尔特成为幽灵前，他是沃尔特本人。在拉玛达出现前，这里叫雷特劳，这是沃尔特拥有时酒店的名字。雷特劳反过来念就是沃尔特。这太荒诞地诡异了，太像《闪灵》里的“redrum”了，很难不怀疑沃尔特从一开始就策划了这一切闹鬼的事。
The Retlaw Hotel opened in 1923. Apparently there wasn't a lot to write about those days because the town newspaper devoted 22 pages to the hotel's opening.
雷特劳酒店于1923年开业。显然那时候没什么可写的，因为当地报纸用了22页来报道酒店开业。
One article took up a full page describing the cigar case in the lobby, the second longest cigar case in the entire state. The Retlaw was a class act. The rooms had chenille carpeting, velvet drapes, and furniture carved out of mahogany wood. There were even special rooms for traveling salesmen with panels that folded down from the wall to display their wares.
有一篇文章用整整一页描述了大厅里的雪茄柜，全州第二长的雪茄柜。雷特劳是一个档次很高的地方。房间里有雪尼尔地毯、天鹅绒窗帘和桃花心木雕刻的家具。甚至还有供出差销售员使用的房间，墙上有折叠面板来展示他们的商品。
There was a big party to celebrate the opening. In between all the dancing, 250 guests feasted on breast of milk-fed chicken, petit fours, and strangely, Saltines. Walter Schroeder made a toast: "Tonight I present the people of Fond du Lac with as fine a hotel as it is possible to build."
开业时有一场大派对。在跳舞的间隙，250位宾客品尝了牛奶喂养的鸡胸肉、小点心，奇怪的是，还有苏打饼干。沃尔特·施罗德祝酒说：“今晚，我向丰迪拉克的民众奉献了能建造出的最好的酒店。”
Which, in itself, might be another clue. Whoever talks like that except at the ironic speech leading up to the big fire or the sinking of the sturdiest ship ever built? It's like the hotel version of, honey, I love you so much and there's something really special I've been meaning to ask you. Oh, never mind, you've got a flight to catch. It can wait.
这本身可能就是另一个线索。除了在那场预示大火或最坚固的船沉没的讽刺演讲前，谁会那么说话？这就像酒店版的“亲爱的，我爱你胜过一切，我有一件特别的事情要问你……噢，算了，你要赶飞机，等下再说吧。”
Walter Schroeder was a man of accomplishment. At 14, he got a job as a reporter for his local newspaper. At 16, he started his own paper. At 21, he formed what would become the largest insurance agency in the state. By 24, his name had already appeared in the book, Notable Men of Wisconsin. And by the time he was 30, he was considered one of the most successful hotel operators the state had ever known.
沃尔特·施罗德是个有成就的人。14岁时，他成为当地报纸的记者。16岁时，他创办了自己的报社。21岁时，他组建了后来成为该州最大的保险代理机构的公司。24岁时，他的名字就出现在《威斯康星州杰出人物》一书中。到30岁时，他被认为是该州有史以来最成功的酒店运营商之一。
The more I learned about Walter the man, the less Walter the ghost made sense. Especially after I spoke with Gary Simic, the head of the library named after Walter, at the Milwaukee School of Engineering.
我对沃尔特本人了解得越多，沃尔特这个鬼魂就越不合理。特别是在我与密尔沃基工程学院以沃尔特名字命名的图书馆负责人加里·西米克交谈之后。
Every morning for the last 17 years, Gary's been greeted by Walter's portrait opposite the front door. He says Walter looks like somebody's good-natured uncle.
过去17年里，加里每天早上都被正对前门的沃尔特肖像问候。他说沃尔特看起来像某个人的好心大叔。
From what we know about Walter, he was very nice man. Very generous, very charitable man. He was a man that liked people. He was famous for his dinner parties that he held at the Schroeder Hotel, the old Schroeder Hotel in Milwaukee.
据我们了解，沃尔特是个非常好的人。非常慷慨，非常慈善。他是个喜欢人的人。他因在密尔沃基老施罗德酒店举办的晚宴而闻名。
I remember in the archives seeing a picture of him at one of these dinner parties. And, you know, people are laughing and he was a very gracious host. Seemed to enjoy people.
我记得在档案馆里看到过他在晚宴上的照片。人们在欢笑，他是一位非常亲切的主人。似乎很喜欢人们。
When Walter died, a foundation was started to distribute his many millions of dollars throughout Wisconsin. So now there's all these places that have Walter's name on them. There's the Walter Schroeder Health Complex at Marquette University. There's the Walter Schroeder Intensive Care Unit at St. Mary's Hospital. There's even a Walter Schroeder student dormitory.
沃尔特去世后，一个基金会被成立，将他的数百万美元分发到威斯康星州。所以现在有许多地方都冠有沃尔特的名字。有马凯特大学的沃尔特·施罗德健康中心。有圣玛丽医院的沃尔特·施罗德重症监护室。甚至还有一个沃尔特·施罗德学生宿舍。
In addition to that, four of Walter Schroeder's seven hotels are still standing. Besides the Ramada, there's The Astor, The Wisconsin, and The Hotel Schroeder, Walter's favorite.
此外，沃尔特·施罗德的七家酒店中有四家还在营业。除了拉玛达，还有阿斯特酒店、威斯康星酒店和施罗德酒店，沃尔特的挚爱。
Which raises the question, why would Walter have chosen to spend his death tromping around a hotel that wasn't even his top choice in life? So I made some calls. I started with the Walter Schroeder wing of a YMCA in Brown Deer, Wisconsin.
这就产生了一个问题，为什么沃尔特选择在死后到处徘徊在一个他生前并不是最喜欢的酒店呢？所以我打了一些电话。我先拨打了威斯康星州布朗迪尔的基督教青年会沃尔特·施罗德分部。
Front Desk, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] speaking. How may I help you?
前台，[听不清] speaking。有什么可以帮您的？
Hi, is this the Walter Schroeder Aquatic Center? I have a question to ask you. It might sound a little unusual. Are you aware that the ghost of Walter Schroeder is haunting the Ramada Inn in Fond du Lac, Wisconsin?
您好，这是沃尔特·施罗德水上中心吗？我有个问题。听起来可能有点不同寻常。您知道沃尔特·施罗德的鬼魂在威斯康星州丰迪拉克的拉玛达酒店闹鬼吗？
Well, OK. Off the record, but whatever. You can use what you want. They say he haunts here.
噢，好的。非正式地说，随便吧。你想怎么用就怎么用。他们说他在我们这儿也闹鬼。
They do? They do not.
他们这么说？他们才不会。
I swear to you they say that. There's a guy who actually quit because he was freaked out. It's like an ongoing scary thing with the camp kids too.
我发誓他们真的这么说。有个员工其实因为被吓坏了辞职了。这对营地的孩子们来说也一直是个可怕的事情。
They're all like afraid of Walter?
他们都怕沃尔特吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Really?
真的吗？
Yep.
是的。
Next I called the Scottish Rite Masonic Lodge in Milwaukee. Walter was a proud mason for 30 years. When he died, they honored Walter's memory by naming a lounge after him, Walter's Lounge. Dick, the custodian, answered the phone.
接着我拨通了密尔沃基苏格兰礼仪共济会小屋。沃尔特是30年的骄傲会员。当他去世时，他们以他的名字命名了一间休息室——沃尔特休息室。保管人迪克接了电话。
Hello, Scottish Rite.
喂，苏格兰礼仪。
Is this the Mason's Lodge in Milwaukee?
这是密尔沃基的共济会小屋吗？
Yes.
是的。
And you guys have a Walter Schroeder Lounge, right?
你们有个沃尔特·施罗德休息室，对吧？
Yes, we do. Walter Schroeder. Yes.
是的，我们有。沃尔特·施罗德。是的。
Did you know that Walter Schroeder's ghost is actually haunting the Ramada Inn in Fond du Lac, Wisconsin?
您知道沃尔特·施罗德的鬼魂实际上在威斯康星州丰迪拉克的拉玛达酒店闹鬼吗？
Is that right? Well, I'm custodial here and I'm the guy that can tell you the noises I hear at night, I don't know.
是这样吗？我是保管人，我是能告诉你我晚上听到的声音的人，但我不知道。
What's the Walter Schroeder Lounge like?
沃尔特·施罗德休息室是什么样的？
Well, the Walter Schroeder Lounge has got three large chandeliers in it. It has a baby grand piano in it.
嗯，沃尔特·施罗德休息室里有三个大吊灯。里面有一架三角钢琴。
Wow. Did Walter play piano?
哇。沃尔特会弹钢琴吗？
Well, that's the thing. I'll tell you now, I've heard the piano play and no one's been in here.
这正是重点。我现在告诉你，我听过钢琴在响，而屋里根本没人。
It's Walter?
那是沃尔特？
That's Walter. Part of him is here all the time.
那是沃尔特。他的一部分一直在这儿。
Poor Walter.
可怜的沃尔特。
Yeah, poor Walter.
是的，可怜的沃尔特。
Poor Walter. In life, he was this great guy. He built empires and hosted grand parties and gave away tons of money to organizations he believed in. But in death, according to the people all up and down the state of Wisconsin, he spends his days knocking glasses off shelves, and scaring little children at the pool, playing the piano, and swiping small bills from cash registers, and taking flash photographs of unsuspecting teenage girls.
可怜的沃尔特。在世时，他是个伟大的人。他建立帝国，举办盛大的聚会，并向他相信的组织捐赠了巨额资金。但在死后，据威斯康星州各地的人们所说，他每天把玻璃杯从架子上推倒，在游泳池里吓唬小孩子，弹钢琴，从收银机里偷小额钞票，还给毫无防备的少女拍闪光照片。
Gary Simic at the Walter Schroeder Library has his work cut out for him, preserving Walter's memory.
沃尔特·施罗德图书馆的加里·西米克有很重的任务要完成，那就是维护沃尔特的记忆。
We try to keep it alive. When we do our teaching and our bibliographic and library instruction, we always mention who he was and why he was important.
我们试图让记忆存活。当我们做教学和书目及图书馆指导时，我们总是提到他是谁，为什么他很重要。
So how does it make you feel that for a lot of people in Fond du Lac, Walter Schroeder is nothing more than-- he's just a ghost?
那么对于丰迪拉克的许多人来说，沃尔特·施罗德只是一个鬼魂，这让你感觉如何？
Well, I feel bad about that. I think they need to know a little bit more about Walter. He was a nice guy and this has been my place. And if not for him, we wouldn't be here.
嗯，我为此感到难过。我觉得他们需要多了解一点沃尔特。他是个好人，这里曾经是我的地方。如果没有他，我们不会在这。
So this is how it goes. You live your life perfectly, and then you die. And no matter what, your fate is out of your hands. If you're lucky, your legacy will carry on. If you're like Walter, you'll get blamed for the mildly bad behavior of every ghost in the state of Wisconsin.
事情就是这样。你完美地过完一生，然后死去。无论如何，你的命运都不在你手中。如果你幸运，你的遗产会传承下去。如果你像沃尔特，你会因为威斯康星州每个鬼魂的轻微恶行而被责怪。
What is so unfair about the whole thing is that every time Walter gets blamed, wrongly, for flushing a toilet in the middle of the night, or switching the TV to say, live coverage of the Senate Finance Committee, the real Walter is being remembered and forgotten at the same time.
整件事最不公平的地方在于，每当沃尔特被错误地责怪在半夜冲厕所，或者把电视切换到参议院财政委员会的直播时，真正的沃尔特同时被铭记和遗忘了。
Starlee Kine. Coming up, whose heart doesn't break for a freezer full of Espteins? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
斯塔莉·基恩。接下来，谁会对满满一冰箱的爱泼斯坦家族感到心碎？从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台节目继续，稍后回来。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our program, stories of people and how they're remembered. Mostly how they're remembered incorrectly.
今天在我们的节目中，有关于人们以及他们如何被铭记的故事。主要是关于他们如何被错误地铭记。
Before we start act three of our program, we have two more little stories from the StoryCorps project, a project devoted to preserving people's memories. Both of these are reunions of a sort captured on tape.
在我们开始第三幕之前，我们还有两个来自StoryCorps项目的短故事，一个致力于保存人们记忆的项目。这两个都是在磁带上捕捉到的重聚。
The first one is between two men who spent their childhoods together at a psychiatric hospital and recently united at the StoryCorps recording booth after 40 years.
第一个是两个一起在精神病院度过童年的男人，在40年后最近在StoryCorps录音棚团聚。
The second one is kind of self-explanatory.
第二个是不言自明的。
I'm seeing you after 40 years, and I'm seeing fear in you. And let me ask you a very important question, do you feel institutionalized?
40年后我见到你，我在你眼中看到了恐惧。让我问你一个非常重要的问题，你觉得被体制化了吗？
No.
没有。
Because I'd like you to come out of that shell, man. Because you're not free in that shell. And I want you to be free.
因为我想让你走出那个壳，伙计。因为你待在那个壳里并不自由。我希望你自由。
I'm free. I do what I want now. But the only thing is--
我自由。我现在想做什么就做什么。但唯一的事情是——
But you're still scared.
但你还是很害怕。
No I'm not.
不，我没有。
Yes you are. And I want to tell you something else. Don't stop having interest in women. You're a free man and you should feel that maybe you could pick up a lady or meet a lady.
你有。我想再告诉你一件事。别停止对女性的兴趣。你是个自由人，你应该觉得自己也许可以去追求一位女士或认识一位女士。
I have one.
我有一个。
That's great.
那太棒了。
Her name is Marion.
她叫玛丽昂。
And another thing. What you should do is make your home more comfortable to live in. Get yourself a CD player, listen to some music. Don't stay in that shell. Do you do a lot of reading?
还有一件事。你应该做的是让你的家住得更舒服。给自己买个CD播放机，听听音乐。别待在壳里。你经常读书吗？
Yes. Dirty novels.
是的。肮脏的小说。
Well, dirty novels is all right. That's not against the law. That's why they sell them, Donald. You're not allowing yourself to exercise your freedom, man, and that's what I want you to do, man. Because that'll make me real happy and you'll be able to come out of that shell, man. Because I really don't want you in that shell for the rest of your life. That's the way I feel about it, man.
嗯，肮脏小说没问题。那不违法。这就是为什么他们会卖它们，唐纳德。你没让自己行使自由，伙计，这就是我希望你做的。因为那会让我真正开心，你就能走出那个壳了。因为我真的不想让你余生都待在那个壳里。这就是我的感受。
Go ahead, Donald, I want to hear you. I haven't seen you in 40 years.
继续，唐纳德，我想听你说。我已经40年没见到你了。
That fear in that darn, lousy hospital is still in my system.
那种在那该死的、糟糕的医院里的恐惧还在我的系统里。
Yeah, well you're never going to get rid of that. But guess what?
是的，好吧，你永远也摆脱不了那个。但你猜怎么着？
I might get rid of it. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] is gone.
我也许能摆脱它。[听不清]不见了。
The memory is always going to be there. But guess what? You don't have to live it for the rest of your life.
记忆总是会存在的。但你猜怎么着？你不必余生都活在其中。
I used to bite my fingers about [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
我过去常常咬手指关于[听不清]。
Donald, they don't have that many hospitals to put anybody in no more.
唐纳德，他们再也没有那么多医院可以收容任何人了。
I know.
我知道。
We're not living in that era anymore. That era is dead.
我们不再生活在那个时代了。那个时代已经死了。
It's dead. It's dead and buried.
它死了。它死了并被埋葬了。
You're free, man. You don't have to take that. Am I right, Donald?
你是自由的，伙计。你不必接受那个。我是对的吗，唐纳德？
Right.
对。
Say it loud and clear.
大声清楚地说出来。
Right, 100%.
对，百分之百。
Can you tell me about the day I was born?
你能告诉我我出生的那天吗？
The doctor took you away quickly because they had asked if I wanted to hold you. And I said, no, because I was afraid if I held you I wouldn't be able to give you up. So they took you away crying and that was all I saw. And they didn't put me in the maternity ward because they were afraid that would be too hard for me. They just put me in the women's ward.
医生很快把你抱走了，因为他们问我是否想抱你。我说不，因为我怕如果我抱了你，我就舍不得放弃你了。所以他们把你抱走了，你当时在哭，那就是我看到的全部。他们没把我放在产房，因为他们怕这对我也太难了。他们只是把我放在妇女病房。
And I remember one of the nurses coming up after you were born and I was crying a lot. And she just came up and she just talked to me for a really long time. And she said, you know, it's going to be OK. It just takes time.
我记得你出生后，其中一个护士走过来，我哭得很厉害。她走过来跟我说了很久的话。她说，你知道，一切都会好起来的。只是需要时间。
And it took, I don't know, about five years before I stopped thinking about you every day and crying to just thinking about you every week. To the point where it only happened about once a month, but it still made me sad.
我想，大概五年之后我才停止每天想起你而哭泣，变成每周想起你一次。以至于它变成一个月只有一次，但还是让我难过。
So I have one more question, and it's the big one you've been waiting for. You now know having lived through it what the consequences of choosing to give me up are, so knowing what you know now, would you do it again?
所以我有最后一个问题，这是你一直期待的大问题。你现在经历过这一切，知道放弃我的后果是什么，所以知道了这一切，你会再做一次吗？
Well, of course knowing what I know now I wouldn't do it again. I remember I used to talk to you a lot when I was pregnant and explain the whole situation, why I had to do this. That I wasn't ready to be a mother. I didn't have a father for you.
嗯，当然知道了这些，我不会再做一次。我记得我怀孕时常和你说话，解释整个情况，为什么我必须这样做。我还没准备好做母亲。我没能给你一个父亲。
I was really sure of myself, I remember that. That this was the best decision. But now I wouldn't even think about it because the separation and the loss is just way too hard. I mean, we have a relationship now and it's great. You've sort of become part of the family, but I missed 20 years. And you can't ever get that back.
我那时对自己很确定，我记得。这绝对是最好的决定。但现在我甚至不会考虑，因为分离和失去实在太痛苦了。我是说，我们现在有了关系，这很棒。你成了家庭的一部分，但我错过了20年。你永远无法追回那些。
Mary Lou Maher and her son Brad Skow. She was a college freshman, just 17, when she found out she was pregnant. Before her were Ralph Tremonte and Donald Weiss. Thanks to Sarah Kramer and the staff of StoryCorps. Their website, storycorps.net.
玛丽·卢·马赫和她的儿子布拉德·斯考。她在发现自己怀孕时，还是个17岁的大学一年级新生。在她之前是拉尔夫·特雷蒙特和唐纳德·魏斯。感谢莎拉·克莱默和StoryCorps的工作人员。他们的网站，storycorps.net。
Which brings us to act three, "Giving Up the Ghosts."
这把我们引向了第三幕，《放弃幽灵》。
We've been talking about how people are remembered all hour long, and of course, some people don't want to remember the dead at all. They turn their backs. Shalom Auslander has this story from the years after he left yeshiva, the Jewish religious school, where he was raised.
我们整整一个小时都在谈论人们如何被铭记，当然，有些人根本不想纪念死者。他们选择了背对过去。沙洛姆·奥斯兰德讲述了这个故事，在他离开犹太宗教学校耶希瓦后的几年里。
ON a good week, you might get two or three dead bodies. Then there were the weeks where it seemed not a single goddamn person would die.
运气好的话，你一周能接到两三具尸体。也有那些似乎一个该死的鬼也不会死的星期。
Impatient, I would phone a man named Mati. Mati was the dispatcher. Anything, I would ask?
我不耐烦地给一个叫马蒂的人打电话。马蒂是调度员。有什么吗？我问。
Nothing, Mati would say. Did I beep you?
什么都没有，马蒂说。我传呼你了吗？
No, I would say. Just checking.
没有，我说。只是确认一下。
When somebody died, their family would call Mati. And Mati would call me.
当有人去世，他们的家人会给马蒂打电话。马蒂会叫我。
Can you work the weekend he would ask.
你能周末工作吗？他会问。
Yeah, sure. I can work the weekend.
当然可以。我可以周末工作。
I was a watcher, a [UNINTELLIGIBLE] in Hebrew. According to Jewish belief, the soul departs the body at the time of death but sort of hangs out until the body is buried. This can be a terribly distressing time for the soul, what with all the not having a body and that being invisible and the floating around. Therefore, the rabbis decreed, from the moment of death to the moment of burial, the body of the deceased must never be left alone.
我是一个守灵人。根据犹太信仰，灵魂在死亡时离开身体，但在安葬前会徘徊在附近。这对灵魂来说可能是一段极度痛苦的时间，因为没有了身体，变得隐形且四处飘浮。因此，拉比们规定，从死亡那一刻到安葬那一刻，死者的尸体必须永远不能独处。
Traditionally, a member of the family would sit with the body. But if nobody in the family wanted to sit with a cold, dead body in the cold, dark basement of a cold, empty funeral home, the family called Mati. And Mati called me.
传统上，家人会守在尸体旁。但如果家人中没人想在寒冷、阴暗的殡仪馆地下室里守着一具冰冷的尸体，家人会给马蒂打电话。然后马蒂叫我。
Flushing Meadows Memorial, Jewel Avenue, Schwartz. Oceanside Memorial, 2111 Atlantic Avenue, Finkel. Riverdale Hebrew Home, Riverside and 268th Street, Dweck.
法拉盛纪念殡仪馆，珠宝大道，施瓦茨。海洋纪念馆，大西洋大道2111号，芬克尔。里弗代尔希伯来之家，河滨大道和268街，德威克。
The ancient rabbis tell us that being a watcher is a wonderful mitzvah, or good deed, for which the almighty blessed be he and the world to come will abundantly reward us. That was all well and good, but Mati paid $85 a night, cash, and that was all the reward I needed.
古代拉比告诉我们，做守灵人是一个美妙的诫命，也就是善行，万能的主在来世会慷慨地奖励我们。这些都很好，但马蒂每晚给85美元现金，那是我需要的全部奖励。
I was 19 years old, living away from home for the first time. I had spent my entire life in yeshivas, raised like a veal in the orthodox skinner box of God. And though I certainly looked the part with my black pants, white button-down shirt, and black wide-brimmed fedora, lately I had been feeling less and less Jerusalem and more and more Gomorrah.
我19岁，第一次离家居住。我一生都在耶希瓦度过，像神圣正统派斯金纳盒里的小牛肉一样被抚养长大。虽然我穿着黑裤子、白扣子衬衫和宽檐黑帽，看起来像那么回事，但最近我感觉自己离耶路撒冷越来越远，离蛾摩拉越来越近。
In the beginning, I could count on two jobs a week. Three if I was lucky. Friday nights paid double, almost $200. But you had to show up Friday evening and stay until after Sabbath ended late on Saturday night. That was a long time to spend with a dead body, even for me. But $200 was $200 and I was no idiot. I was saving up for a 1982 Ford Mustang convertible.
刚开始，我一周能接两份工作。幸运的话三个。周五晚上双倍工资，将近200美元。但你必须周五晚上出现，一直待到周六晚上安息日结束。那是一段漫长的时间，甚至对我来说也一样。但200美元就是200美元，我又不傻。我正攒钱买一辆1982年的福特野马敞篷车。
It was surprisingly pleasant work. The dead were my kind of people.
这份工作出奇地愉快。死人是我喜欢的那类人。
Bring a pillow said Mati the first time he called, and a tehillim. Tehillim is Hebrew for the book of psalms. And a snack, he added.
带个枕头，第一次给我打电话的马蒂说，还有一本《诗篇》。《诗篇》是希伯来语的诗歌集。再带个零食，他补充说。
What kind of a snack? I asked.
什么零食？我问。
Whatever you want, said Mati.
随你便，马蒂说。
Like what, potato chips?
比如薯片？
Potato chips are fine.
薯片行。
Can I bring a sandwich?
能带三明治吗？
What kind of sandwich, Mati asked?
什么三明治，马蒂问？
Tuna?
金枪鱼？
There was a pause while Mati considered the theological implications. You can bring a sandwich, Mati decreed.
有一阵沉默，马蒂在考虑神学意义。你可以带三明治，马蒂裁定道。
Cue Gardens Funeral, Jewel Avenue, Bernstein. My first job. Mati told me to be there no later than 7 o'clock in the evening our I wouldn't be able to get in. The security guard would have an envelope for me with $85 and in it and he would show me to the body.
邱园殡仪馆，珠宝大道，伯恩斯坦。我的第一份工作。马蒂告诉我晚上7点前必须到，否则就进不去了。保安会给我一个装有85美元的信封，带我去看尸体。
I'd never been in a funeral home before. The main floor was lavishly decorated, Victorian style furniture, heavy, golden drapery, Italian marble. The guard led me across the lobby to a steel door in the back. We made our way down the bare wooden stairs to the basement where they kept the bodies, and I remember the old adage about never looking inside the kitchen of your favorite restaurant.
我以前从没去过殡仪馆。主楼装修豪华，维多利亚风格家具、沉重的金色窗帘、意大利大理石。保安领我穿过大厅，来到后部的一扇铁门前。我们顺着裸露的木楼梯下到存放尸体的地下室，我记得那句关于永远不要走进你最喜欢餐馆厨房的格言。
There was no drapery and there was no marble. There were a lot of rusty pipes and a noisy boiler and a dangerously overloaded fuse box. The only furniture, aside from some spare hospital gurneys, was a battered old metal folding chair.
那里没有窗帘，没有大理石。只有锈迹斑斑的管道、吵闹的锅炉和极其危险、负荷过重的保险箱。除了几张备用的担架床外，唯一的家具是一把破旧的金属折叠椅。
There you go, said the guard. There's a toilet at the end of the hall.
就是这了，保安说。走廊尽头有厕所。
I'm here for Bernstein, I said. Is there a Bernstein here?
我是来找伯恩斯坦的，我说。这儿有伯恩斯坦吗？
He pointed to the large stainless steel door of a commercial refrigerator. Bernstein, he said. I'll be here another 15 minutes if you need anything.
他指着一个大型商业冰箱的巨大不锈钢门。伯恩斯坦，他说。如果你需要什么，我还在那儿待15分钟。
I opened my backpack and took out a bottle of purple Gatorade and my book of psalms. Blessed is he who goes in the path of their-- oh, brother. It seemed a bit to be given Bernstein that sort of advice.
我打开背包，拿出一瓶紫色佳得乐和我的《诗篇》。那顺从他道的人是有福的……噢，兄弟。给伯恩斯坦这种建议似乎有点多余。
I don't know about you, Bernstein, I said, but I'm beat. I laid down on the gurney, put on my Walkman, smoked half a joint, and tried to sleep. I was pretty sure there was no such thing as a soul. And even if there were, I was pretty sure that a glassy-eyed teenage pothead munching his way through a bag of Doritos Cool Ranch tortilla chips wasn't going to offer it a whole heap of consolation.
我不了解你，伯恩斯坦，我说，但我累了。我躺在担架上，戴上随身听，抽了一半大麻，试图睡觉。我相当确定根本没有灵魂这回事。即使有，我也不觉得一个眼神空洞、嚼着多力多滋玉米片的少年毒虫能给它带来任何安慰。
Business was good. I enjoyed the independence. I made my own hours. No meetings, no small talk. It was just me, my sandwich, a small bag of marijuana, a pack of smokes, Guns and Roses "Appetite for Destruction," and some dead guy in a big steel fridge.
生意不错。我享受这份独立。我决定自己的时间。没有会议，没有闲聊。只有我和我的三明治、一小袋大麻、一包烟、枪与玫瑰的《毁灭欲望》唱片，还有一个存放在巨大钢制冰箱里的死人。
Unfortunately, Jewish law stated that a watcher is only permitted to watch one body at a time. If there was only one body in the funeral home, it was clear which body I was watching and there was no need for me to see it. Occasionally, though, the fridge was packed floor to ceiling, which meant I was required to open the door and make actual eye contact with the body I was meant to be watching. Like most things biblical, this was a less than foolproof method that led to a certain amount of confusion.
不幸的是，犹太法律规定，守灵人一次只能看守一具尸体。如果殡仪馆里只有一具尸体，很清楚我在看守哪具，我也不需要真的见到它。但偶尔，冰箱里塞满了尸体，这意味着我必须打开门，与我负责看守的身体进行真正的目光接触。像大多数圣经的东西一样，这是一种不太可靠的方法，导致了一定程度的困惑。
One night I was told to watch an Epstein. Inside the fridge I found three of them, a David Epstein, a Gerald Epstein, and a Motia Epstein. I caught the funeral director just before he left for the night. Yep, he said, we got us a whole load of Epsteins.
一天晚上，有人告诉我去看守一个爱泼斯坦。在冰箱里，我发现了三个，大卫·爱泼斯坦、杰拉尔德·爱泼斯坦和莫蒂亚·爱泼斯坦。殡仪馆老板临走前我截住了他。对，他说，我们这儿有整整一堆爱泼斯坦。
We stepped inside the fridge. Which Epstein is mine? I asked.
我们走进冰箱。哪个爱泼斯坦是我的？我问。
Which Epstein in mine, he repeated as he checked their tags. As if it were some sort of deep, existential question mankind has pondered since time began.
哪个爱泼斯坦是我的？他重复道，检查着标签。就好像这是人类自从开始思考以来一直在反思的深奥存在主义问题。
Which Epstein is mine? How will I find my Epstein?
哪个爱泼斯坦是我的？我怎么找到我的爱泼斯坦？
He suggested I cover my bases and take a good, solid look at each of the Epsteins. Can't go wrong that way, he said.
他建议我两手准备，好好看看每个爱泼斯坦。那样绝对没错，他说。
Really? I asked. You sure that's kosher?
真的？我问。你确定这符合教规？
Kosher with me, he said.
我这儿符合，他说。
A ghoulish economics developed. All that dying was making me a nice living. One dead paid my AmEx bill. Three deads covered my share of the rent. A weekend job covered me for weed and food, and soon I was done for the month. Every dead after that was just gravy. Two deads got me some new Air Jordans, three deads was a new TV. If Mati could have guaranteed me a solid extra dead a week, I would have ordered HBO. But I was no fool. I was saving up for a 1982 Ford Mustang convertible.
一种恐怖的经济学发展出来了。所有的死亡让我有了不错的收入。一个死人付清了我的账单。三个死人支付了我的房租。周末工作够我买大麻和吃的，很快我就完成了每月的任务。之后的每一个死人都是额外奖金。两个死人给我买了双新乔丹，三个死人是一台新电视。如果马蒂能保证每周多给我一个死人，我就会订购HBO了。但我又不傻。我正攒钱买一辆1982年的福特野马敞篷车。
Death didn't bother me. I'd never personally known anybody that died, but after 19 years in orthodox yeshiva, I was pretty familiar with death. The Jewish holidays all seemed to involve someone killing us, someone trying to kill us, or our praying to God so that he doesn't kill us himself.
死亡没困扰我。我从没亲身认识过死人，但在正统派耶希瓦19年后，我对死亡相当熟悉。犹太人的节日似乎都涉及有人杀我们，有人试图杀我们，或者我们祈祷上帝别让他自己杀我们。
Jewish history was the same. If the Babylonians weren't trying to kill us, it was the Romans. If it wasn't the Romans, it was the Spanish. And if it wasn't the Spanish, it was the Germans.
犹太历史也一样。如果巴比伦人没试着杀我们，就是罗马人。如果不是罗马人，就是西班牙人。如果不是西班牙人，就是德国人。
Every Holocaust Remembrance Day, we were led into the school auditorium to watch hours and hours of newsreel footage of concentration camps and gas chambers. So graphic was the footage that we needed special permission forms signed by our parents. This was never a problem for me.
每个大屠杀纪念日，我们都被带到学校礼堂观看数小时关于集中营和毒气室的新闻片。画面极其生动，我们需要父母签署特别许可单。对我来说这从来不是问题。
My mother lived for death. Nothing made her happier than sadness. Nothing made her more joyful than melancholy. She worked as a medical assistant for a local pediatrician and the tragedies she witnessed there were at least as much a perk as the dental coverage.
我妈妈为死亡而活。没有什么比悲伤更让她快乐。没有什么比忧郁更让她感到喜悦。她在当地儿科医生那做医疗助理，她在那见证的悲剧，至少和牙科保险一样算是个津贴。
A boy came into the office today, she would say at dinner. Hepatitis. She would pause to take a long, slow sip of her soup. C, she would add.
今天有个男孩来办公室，她会在晚饭时说。肝炎。她会停下来喝一口长长的、慢慢的汤。C型，她会补充道。
My father would pound the table with his fist. Do we have to listen to this crap every goddamn meal, he would bark, taking his plate into the kitchen to finish eating.
我父亲会愤怒地用拳头敲桌子。每顿饭我们都要听这些垃圾吗？他会咆哮着，拿着盘子到厨房吃完。
Indeed, we did.
的确，我们要听。
It's a death sentence, she would say once he'd left. Kid doesn't have a chance.
这是死刑，她会说，等他走后。孩子根本没机会。
Lung infections, genetic disease, spinal meningitis. I ate as quickly as I could hoping to get through dessert before the gastrointestinal disorders.
肺部感染、遗传病、脊髓脑膜炎。我尽快吃完，希望能赶在胃肠道紊乱的话题前吃完甜点。
I had a brother who died years before I was born. His name was Jeffy. Between Jeffy and my relatives who died in the Holocaust, my mother had more pictures of the dead on our walls than she had of the living.
我有个哥哥，在我出生前几年去世了。他叫杰菲。在杰菲和大屠杀中死去的亲戚之间，我妈妈墙上挂的死人照片比活人的还多。
By the time I was nine years old, my father drank heavily and physically abused my older brother. My brother hated my mother and resented me. My mother loathed my brother and doted on me and my sister. My sister hated my brother and defended my mother. I envied my brother and pitied my mother. And my father hated us all. All of this, the family story goes, because Jeffy died.
到我9岁时，我父亲酗酒，并虐待我哥哥。我哥哥恨我妈妈，怨恨我。我妈妈厌恶我哥哥，溺爱我和姐姐。我姐姐恨我哥哥，保护我妈妈。我嫉妒我哥哥，同情我妈妈。而我父亲恨我们所有人。全家故事说，这一切都是因为杰菲死了。
You should never know the pain of losing a child, my mother said to me. Between my mother and my rabbis, death wasn't the worst thing I could imagine. In fact, by the time I was 19, I couldn't care less about it.
你永远不该知道失去孩子的痛苦，我妈妈对我说。在我妈妈和我的拉比之间，死亡并不是我能想象的最坏的事情。事实上，到我19岁时，我根本不在乎它了。
A few months after I started, Mati hired a second watcher. Business was good, Mati was branching out, expanding to meet customer demand. And I didn't like it. The new watcher's name was David. David was Mati's cousin, and I was convinced he was receiving preferential treatment. He was given nearly every weekend job, the $200 types. And I was pretty sure he getting first pick of the midweek gigs as well. Impatient, I phoned Mati.
我开始工作几个月后，马蒂雇了第二个守灵人。生意很好，马蒂正在扩展业务，以满足客户需求。但我没喜欢它。新守灵人的名字叫大卫。大卫是马蒂的表弟，我深信他受到了优待。他得到了几乎每个周末的工作，200美元那种。我很确定他也优先挑选了平日的工作。我不耐烦地给马蒂打电话。
Anything? I would ask.
有什么吗？我问。
Nothing, Mati would say. Did I beep you?
什么都没有，马蒂说。我传呼你了吗？
No, I would say, just checking. I'll beep you, he would say.
没有，我说，只是确认一下。我传呼你时，他会说。
The third watcher Mati hired was named Schmoa. Schmoa was an ultra-orthodox yeshiva student who knew Mati from synagogue and cynically pretended that the money didn't matter to him. I need the mitzvahs, he would say to Mati, clapping his hands with righteous glee.
马蒂雇的第三个守灵人叫施莫亚。施莫亚是一个超正统派耶希瓦学生，在犹太会堂认识马蒂，并愤世嫉俗地假装钱对他没意义。我需要积攒善行，他会对马蒂说，带着正义的喜悦拍手。
Listen, rabbi, I thought, back of the line. You've got the rest of your life to earn rewards for the next world. I'm trying to buy a car in this one.
听着，拉比，我想，排队去吧。你有一辈子去为来世积攒奖励。我正在攒钱买车。
Pretty soon I was down to one lousy dead every two or three weeks. Impatient, I phoned Mati.
很快，我两三周才接到一个死人。我不耐烦地给马蒂打电话。
Anything? I asked.
有什么吗？我问。
Nothing, Mati said. Did I beep you?
什么都没有，马蒂说。我传呼你了吗？
Nothing? I asked. Nobody's died in the past three weeks in all of Brooklyn and Queens?
什么都没有？我问。过去三周布鲁克林和皇后区没人死吗？
Blessed is he who heals the sick, said Mati.
医治病人的人是有福的，马蒂说。
Oh, bullshit, I said, and slammed down the phone. Goddamn death was all about who you know.
噢，胡扯，我说，并砰地挂断了电话。该死的死亡全都是关于你认识谁。
Mati never beeped me again. And frankly, I didn't want him to.
马蒂再也没呼叫过我。老实说，我也不想他呼叫。
I'd had almost a whole month off from death. No funeral homes, no refrigerators. No suffering of any kind when my mother called to tell me that my grandmother had passed away. She's at the Zion Gate Memorial Home, she said. You know where it is.
我从死亡中得到了将近一个月的假期。没有殡仪馆，没有冰箱。当我妈妈打电话告诉我奶奶去世时，没有任何痛苦。她在锡安门纪念殡仪馆，她说。你知道它在哪。
My mother had been proud of my watching career and had been said to hear of its sudden demise. She was like a Yankee fan that knew someone who worked for the team. She'd known someone on the inside of sorrow, her favorite sport.
我妈妈为我的守灵事业感到自豪，听到它突然结束感到很难过。她就像一个认识球队员工的洋基队球迷。她认识一个悲伤内部的人，那是她最喜欢的运动。
I know where it is, I said.
我知道它在哪，我说。
She blew her nose into the phone and sighed deeply. So unexpected, she said. That's the hardest part. My grandmother had died from Alzheimer's, a disease she'd had for well over seven years.
她对着电话擦了擦鼻子，深深地叹了口气。真突然，她说。那是这最难的部分。我奶奶死于阿尔茨海默症，她患病已经七年多了。
I got to Zion Gate, walked heavily down the stairs, threw my bag on a nearby gurney, and dropped into my old seat on the metal folding chair beside the fridge.
我到了锡安门，沉重地走下楼梯，把包扔在附近的担架上，倒在冰箱旁边折叠椅上的老位子上。
I didn't know my grandmother well. The disease had killed her mind years before it finally came back for her body. But I had some fond memories of her from my childhood. Memories I desperately ran through my mind, trying for once to feel something, anything for the dead body inside that fridge.
我不太了解我奶奶。疾病在身体终于被带走前，早已夺走了她的心智。但我有一些童年时期关于她的美好回忆。我拼命在脑海中闪过这些回忆，试图为冰箱里的死尸感受点什么。
I remembered how when I was young she would bring us Rice Krispy treats that she made with real Fluffernutter, which everyone knows isn't kosher.
我记得小时候她会带我们用真正的棉花糖做的米花饼，每个人都知道那是不合规的。
They're just kids, she would say to my mother. And when my mother's back was turned, she'd put her finger over her lips to keep us quiet and silently hand us boxes of non-kosher Chiclets chewing gum.
他们只是孩子，她会对我妈说。当妈妈转过身时，她会把手指放在唇边让我们保持安静，然后悄悄塞给我们几盒非教规的奇克莱兹口香糖。
Don't tell your mother, she'd whisper.
别告诉你妈，她会轻声说。
But it was no use. I didn't know her that well and I sat there fuming, picturing my mother upstairs, the belle of the misery ball. Should be sighing and hugging and reciting Yiddish aphorisms about the inescapable brutality of our wretched lives.
但这没用。我不怎么了解她，我坐在那儿生闷气，想象着我妈妈在楼上，悲剧舞会的焦点。应该在叹气、拥抱并背诵关于我们悲惨人生无法逃避的残酷的意第绪格言。
I felt like Al Pacino in that mafia movie. Just when I thought I was out, they pull me back in.
我觉得自己像黑帮电影里的阿尔·帕西诺。当我以为已经抽身时，他们又把我拉了回去。
I opened my Gatorade, took a few hits off a joint, put on my Walkman and tried to get some sleep. It was already 11:00 PM and I had to be at my new job at the hardware store early the next morning. Let the rest of them mourn. I was saving up for a 1982 Ford Mustang convertible.
我打开佳得乐，抽了几口大麻，戴上随身听，试图入睡。当时已经晚上11点，我第二天早上还得早起去五金店上班。让别人去哀悼吧。我正攒钱买一辆1982年的福特野马敞篷车。
Shalom Auslander. His book, Foreskin's Lament , was a 2007 New York Times Notable Book of the Year. It has just come out in paperback.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德。他的书《包皮之叹》是2007年《纽约时报》年度值得关注书籍。刚刚出了平装版。
[MUSIC - "LIVE AND LET DIE" BY GUNS 'N' ROSES.
[音乐——枪与玫瑰演唱的《生死关头》]
Our program was produced by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Our protection manager is Seth Lind. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Kevin Clark, Thea Chaloner, and Andy Dixon.
我们的节目由我和莎拉·柯尼格制作，还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、黛安·库克、温迪·多尔、简·费尔特斯和丽莎·波拉克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作经理是塞斯·林德。阿德里安·马蒂奥维兹经营我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼、凯文·克拉克、西亚·查洛纳和安迪·迪克森提供了制作协助。
StoryCorps funders include the Corporation for Public Broadcasting, National Public Radio, the Ford Foundation and the Open Society Institute.
StoryCorps的资助者包括公共广播公司、国家公共广播电台、福特基金会和开放社会基金会。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where right now you can get tickets to our live movie event. That's right, we are doing our radio show in front of a live audience and beaming it to movie theaters all over the country. You can see us one night, April 23, one night only. For tickets, www.thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站，现在那里可以预订我们的现场电影活动门票。没错，我们正在现场观众面前播放我们的广播节目，并向全国的电影院进行转播。你们可以在4月23日观看，仅此一场。订票地址：www.thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia, who describes what it is like for him running our radio station.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ的管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚担任，他描述了他管理电台的感觉。
It was just me, my sandwich, pack of smokes, Guns and Roses "Appetite for Destruction," and a small bag of marijuana.
只有我和我的三明治、一包烟、枪与玫瑰的《毁灭欲望》唱片，还有一小袋大麻。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with my stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。